we built that first location  or what we turned it around for like  using like 15 grand how many locations  do you guys have holy  27 28 locations there's three trucks  that run is that alhambra was still open  main street still open we [ __ ] shut  that block down all that god we shut  that down there was like a helicopter  [ __ ] stop the [ __ ] what was it like a  king just after his collab grand opening  after so i think that was already a huge  buzz right yeah there was like a kindest  flavor right yeah yeah it was it can't  just play it like black sesame  you guys performed uh at the store just  a couple guys had to like like [ __ ]  move a small little crowd and then  everybody's literally just freestyling  the video's still up i was like hey you  guys need to get here because it's  getting crazy and there's a helicopter  just flying around right now that's dope  man they're freaking the city's freaking  they didn't know what's going on i  didn't know